.
, THANK YOU SO MUC
HESSP E BEENONR SEVEJOINING US
SEA THRILLER ANDOST FAMOUSLY
C G.
I APPATG
E
YOU HAASZ UN G
YOUR MIND TONIGHT.
THANKS, ANDERI MEANSLY WE'RE AM
THIS.
ITH IT FOR
A FEW DAYS NOW A OF MY LLEAGUES
SUGEI WAT MY
ED ON SUNDAY
D
NEUSE IT'S, YOU OW
SMALL COMMUNY IN THE DEEP NCE O
EVENT SOIN MY MIND THAT COULD A
OWN BATTERY R PPARY SYSTS
IS THE TRAPOSH
SO I WASIN
THEN.
THATT ON TAI
SOME OTHER TRACK DN
INTEL THAT WAA MILITARY ORIGINB
THERE ARE ATD GOT
CONFIRTIE WAND OF LOUD NOI CONS
WITH AEVENT.
CONFIRMAONI LE
PLOWTHAT WST OUR
ED EVERYBODY TO RAISE GLASS IN
THTHENDAYS THIS RT OF
FUTI. AINT WRONG BUKNY BONES THS
AND SO IT CERTAINL A
SEAY
ANST FEERR TT UGSE FALSE HOPES
KEPT GETNG
AS I O.
>>O -- YOU SAI
IT WAS ON MONDAY THAT YO
LEARNED OF THESE
DEVICES UNDER E WATER PICKED
TND OF AN IMPLOSION?T   THAS,
W,Y, MUL
E CREDIBLE SOURCES.U KNOW, TOOKE
AND I COULDN'T THINKY
A SUB
WOULD BE LOST WHER LOS AE SAME
AND STAYED OUT OTO
WAS ALSO TOLD, A I FIRMATION ONT
DESCENT, THEY WERE A COUE
HU SEA
T
WEIGHTS.
NOW,SHIP
Y S Y HA THAT IN TEYASCENDIN
VEOWT THEY
SOMEC SIGNATURE OF THE
EGINNINGO
N WILL HOPEFULLYLY SHOW WHAT DI
BECAUSE WE A
WE GO
THE DEEPRGENCENES W EX
>> DOZENS UST TRAORDINY EXPEDI
TO THE ITSELF.
YOU'VE ALSO GONE FAR D
I THINK YOU'VE GONE DEEPER THAN
DY INTO
OCEAN.
OTHE
GE
BUT --
DEEP, YEAH.ENOUR N , YO
OWN DESIGNED
AS
EXIDUGE STANDARD
SAFETY
RE NOT
TAKIER BOARD.CT>> WOULD YOUPASS
SUBMERSIBLE THAT HAD NOT
THROUGE STDAE
NOT AT ALL.
UB THACHALLENGER DEEAFELY
THHATITA
WE MAD DIVES I
SUTHAT SE SEATER WED
THAT MELGINEER-D
VEHICLE WOBENLY PILOTS
S.ER.S Y  ONN
SO YOU ID THE
RISKS.
WILLING TOR TAKE IT UPON
MYSELF TO ASK SOMEONE ELSE TTAKK
INOT WE'D GOUGH ALL
PROTOCOLS AN
THAT YOU HAVE WI B.,
BUREAU OIP OR RMAN LLOYDS, SUB
THEY CAL BASICALLYCEIFI THINK I
UNCOONUPOUGH THAT RIGOROUS
PROCESS.
>> THIS WA EXPERIMENTAL
ABOUT IT.HERE'S NO QST
'S A CARBON COMPOSITE.U CAN TEL
THATCT KIN
T SIP ERAND WHAT IS THNGER OATNF
ENVIRONMENT?
MPLETELYPPR  THAT SEES ERE., CA
PRESSU, E
LET'S SAY A SCUBA .
GET TWO OR THREE S MULTIP OOU CD
GE OUM TYPE RE.R SOMETHINEERNALD
Y ANDVANTAGES COME INTPLAYSO IFE
COE SECOND YOU
CA CTEY KINDYOU'RE
INTRODE THAT ONTACT WITH EACH O.
THE FILAMENTAN
EPOXY MATRIX THAT IT SIT
AND AT THAT POINT YOU HAVEN FAI.
TH THEIAFOR
SUBMERSIBLTHN VEIVE DAMAGE.INSIU
H ISUSE YOU MA
HAPPENED HERE,ND IT
AT
IF I WERE DI
WARTIFIE I
I KNEWT IF I VE SEV,  THREEGO
BECAUSE YOU ULE EEF ME
TITE.IDIOUS THINK LULLEE CASE
INTO A SENSE OF CONFIDENCE AND .
BUE ARE KNOWN THINGS.
THEY'RE KNOWN WITHIN THE GINEER
COMPANY'SELY OHIS CRITIC O
ACOUSTIC MONITORING OF THEMADE
PRESSURE AS OPPOSED TO A SCAN
E ACCORDINTO COMPANY
CLAIMED NOQU EXISTED
OU PF A SCANE FIVE-INCH-THICK
>> YEAH.>> I KNOCULT TO SAY
OBVIOUWITHOUT READING THE
OFAK SENSORSY HAD
THE S A OBM THEN T S
.Y EY
>> IT'S G WE
BR CK
CAND I THIN IF YOU'RE
BUILDING AE YOAVE SENSORS TO TEO
ITAILING IN THPROCESS  G, YOUS
SUD IT, YOSUBS OR BEIN
AD THS A
FE
BUT I CONSIDER IBAD INIG
OF THEIR DESIGN.L FLAW
THIS DESIGN CONCEPT ESK
QU
TO TR DEEP THAT I
WA IOBVIOUY.
S ANOTHER SUSITHATOURSTIME THATN
COM
CYTWO TITANIUM END
BLANK, YOU'RIN THING.
D LTIMAT
I LIRA THEUY WHO HE S WHEN ITS F
WAS THEN PLA
PURCHASED BY ANOTHER GUY T
OPERATE IT. HIM Y'RTO
THING. IF YOU DIVE THAT
OCWASATHINI T,O WI
AND THEY HAD A IDEA OF E
DOING ACOUSTICOO
EL
WATER INGRESS STARTSO FORCE E LE